AINSLEY: BACK WITH FOX NEWS
ALERT, MAJOR BREAKTHROUGH IN
SEARCH FOR COVID-19 VACCINE.
PETE: JOHNSON & JOHNSON
REVEALING OVERNIGHT IT PROTECTS
MONKEYS AFTER ONE DOZE, HUMAN
TRIALS OF THAT VACCINE BEGIN
TODAY AS COVID-19-RELATED DEATHS
NOW TOP 150,000 IN THE U.S.
BRIAN: WOW, NOW MORE THAN
4.4 MILLION CASES, 7 STATES
REPORTING RECORD HIGH NUMBER OF
DEATHS IN A SINGLE DAY, LET’S
BRING IN DR. DEBORAH BIRX, WHITE
HOUSE CORONAVIRUS RESPONSE
COORDINATOR.
DR. BIRX, ALWAYS GREAT TO SEE
YOU.
THE WORD IS THAT YOU SAY I’M
WORRIED ABOUT THE SOUTH BUT I’M
REALLY WORRIED ABOUT THE
MIDWEST, WHERE?
DOCTOR: SO JUST TO REMIND
EVERYONE ACROSS THE SOUTH STILL
A VERY SERIOUS PANDEMIC ALTHOUGH
THEY ARE STARTING TO SEE THE
GLIMMERS OF HOPE OF IMPROVEMENT
AND WE REALLY WANT TO THANK
GOVERNORS AND MAYOR WHO IS HAVE
WORKED HARD WITH THEIR
POPULATIONS TO ENSURE EVERYONE
WAS WEARING MASKS, DECREASING
SOCIAL GATHERINGS, DECREASING IN
PLACES LIKE BARS AN DECREASING
PARTIES AT HOME WHERE YOU CAN’T
SOCIAL DISTANT.
NOW WE SEE THE VIRUS PROBABLY
BECAUSE OF VACATIONS AND OTHER
REASONS OF TRAVEL MOVING UP INTO
KENTUCKY, TENNESSEE, SOUTHERN
OHIO, MISSOURI, IOWA, KANSAS,
NEBRASKA AND, OF COURSE, WE
CONTINUE TO HAVE PROBLEMS ACROSS
THE WEST COAST, WASHINGTON,
OREGON, CALIFORNIA, IDAHO AND
UTAH AND NOW INCREASES IN
COLORADO.
SO THESE ARE THE STATES THAT WE
CALL YELLOW STATES.
WE BELIEVE THE GOVERNORS AND
MAYORS OF EVERY LOCALITY RIGHT
NOW WOULD MANDATE MASKS FOR
THEIR COMMUNITIES AND EVERY
AMERICAN WOULD WEAR A MASK AND
SOCIALLY DISTANCE AND NOT
CONGREGATE IN LARGE SETTINGS
WHERE YOU CAN’T SOCIALLY
DISTANCE OR WEAR A MASK.
WE CAN REALLY GET CONTROL OF THE
VIRUS AND DRIVE DOWN CASES AS
ARIZONA HAS DONE.
AINSLEY: DR. BIRX, THIS IS
EXCITING NEWS WITH JOHNSON &
JOHNSON GIVING DRUG TO VACCINE
ON MONKEYS AND WORKS ON FIRST
TRY, WHAT DO YOU KNOW ABOUT THIS
AND WHAT MORE CAN YOU TELL US?
DOCTOR: THE EXCITING THING ABOUT
JOHNSON & JOHNSON VACCINE,
TRIALS FROM MODERNA AND PFIZER,
THE JOHNSON & JOHNSON, ALL TO
HAVE VACCINES WERE BUILT ON WHAT
WE CALL KNOWN TECHNOLOGY OR
KNOWN VECTORS SO WE KNEW THE
SAFETY TO BEGIN WITH.
THE JOHNSON & JOHNSON VACCINE IS
EXCITING BECAUSE IT’S A SINGLE
DOSE.
TO SHOW PROTECTION IN MONKEYS
DOES SHORTEN THE TIME PERIOD FOR
DEVELOPMENT BECAUSE YOU READ OUT
BECOMES 30 DAYS QUICKER.
PETE: DOCTOR, YOUR COLLEAGUE
DR. FAUCI SUGGESTED RECENTLY
THAT GOOGLES WOULD WORK EVEN
BETTER OR IN ADDITION TO, YOU’RE
TALKING ABOUT MASKS, PEOPLE HAVE
COME AROUND TO THE REALITY OF
THAT, ARE WE GOING TO LOOK AT
MORE DEMANDS BASED ON WHAT
DR. FAUCI HAS SAID?
DOCTOR: I HAVE SEEN GREAT FACE
SHIELDS AND I’VE SEEN THEM
AROUND THE COUNTRY.
I’VE BEEN OUT TO 14 STATES.
THE ADMINISTRATION SENT ME OUT
TO HOT SPOTS AN YELLOW STATES TO
DELIVER SPECIFIC MESSAGES ABOUT
HOW TO IMPROVE AND PREVENTION
SPREAD IN THEIR COMMUNITIES AND
I’VE GOTTEN TO SEE A LOT OF
EXCITING FACE MASKS OUT THERE
AND FACE MASKS THAT COVER FROM
THE BOTTOM UP AND I THINK THAT’S
REALLY -- I THINK PEOPLE, THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE INNOVATIVE.
THOSE ARE ACTUALLY PRETTY EASY
AND STRAIGHTFORWARD TO MAKE.
MANY UNIVERSITIES AND THOSE WHO
HAVE PRINTERS ARE MAKING FACE
SHIELDS NOW.
THE 3D PRINTERS CAN INCREASE
PRODUCTION AND I THINK OTHERS
ARE MAKING THEM AND THEY ARE
GOING TO BE DECORATED.
PETE: DOCTOR, NO ONE IS
INTERESTED IN DECORATIONS, I
WANT TO KNOW FACE SHIELD OR
GOGGLES IS SOMETHING THAT WE
WILL HEAR NEXT?
IS THIS SOMETHING THAT WILL
BECOME THE NEW GUIDELINES?
DOCTOR: THE MASK IS TO PROTECT
OTHERS, IT’S TO BLOCK THOSE
DROPLETS AND BLOCK THAT
CONTAMINATION THAT HAPPENS WHEN
YOU SPEAK OR SING OR TALK OR
EVEN BREATHE.
THE THING ABOUT THE FACE SHIELDS
WE THINK THAT THAT COULD PROTECT
THE INDIVIDUALS AND THAT IT
WOULD DECREASE THE ABILITY FOR
THEM TO TOUCH THEIR EYES AND
SPREAD VIRUS AS WELL AS THE
DROPLETS COMING TOWARDS THEM.
SO THERE ARE TWO DIFFERENT
TECHNOLOGIES FOR TWO DIFFERENT
REASONS.
BRIAN: UNBELIEVABLE BECAUSE WE
HEARD THE MASKS NOT ONLY PROTECT
PEOPLE FROM YOU BUT YOUR
PROTECTION SO DON’T WEAR A MASK,
WEAR A MASK AND NOW IT CAN HELP
YOU IF IT’S SPREAD AND NOW IT
CAN HELP YOU BLOCK AND NOW
YOU’RE SAYING WEAR GOGGLES.
IT’S UNBELIEVABLE.
ALL RIGHT.
LET’S GET KIDS BACK TO SCHOOL.
DO YOU BELIEVE FROM WHAT YOU
KNOW EVEN IN THE HOTTEST SPOT
THERE’S A WAY TO GET KIDS BACK
TO SCHOOL SAFELY BEING THAT
THEIR TRANSMISSION IS SO LOW,
THE CHANCES OF THEM GETTING IT
IS SO SMALL?
DOCTOR: FIRST, LET’S GO BACK TO
THE TWO STATISTICS, ONE, WE KNOW
FROM EXAMPLES AROUND THE COUNTRY
THAT CHILDREN DO GET INFECTED.
WHAT WE DO KNOW THEY DO BETTER
BY IN LARGE.
THE QUESTION ABOUT WHETHER THEY
ARE LESS TRANSMIT THE VIRUS LESS
STILL OPEN DEBATE.
WE HAVE ONE STUDY NOT DONE IN
THE UNITED STATES AND I THINK
THAT STILL IS AN OPEN QUESTION.
WHEN YOU’RE TALKING ABOUT
PUTTING CHILDREN BACK IN SCHOOL,
THE TEACHERS, THE GRANDPARENTS
THAT ARE HOME IN
MULTIGENERATIONAL --
BRIAN: WE HEARD FROM EXPERTS
SAYING IT’S ALMOST IMPOSSIBLE
FOR KIDS TO SPREAD THIS TO OTHER
KIDS AND ADULTS, YOU’RE SAYING
IT’S NOT TRUE AT ALL.
DOCTOR: WE HAVE ONE STUDY IN
SOUTH KOREA THAT SHOWED PRECISE
FACT.
WHAT I CAN TELL YOU IN THE
UNITED STATES DO I HAVE AN
EXAMPLE POSITIVE OR NEGATIVE
THAT CONFIRMS THAT STUDY AND I
THINK YOU KNOW WITH SCIENTISTS
WE LIKE TO HAVE ALWAYS MORE THAN
ONE STUDY TO CONFIRM IT.
WHAT WE DO KNOW IS CHILDREN
PARTICULARLY CHILDREN UNDER 18
GET MUCH LESS SICK AS WELL AS
PEOPLE UNDER 35.
THAT MEANS ALSO THAT WE CALL
ASYMPTOMATIC AND MORE LIKELY TO
SPREAD THE VIRUS WITHOUT THEM
KNOWING THAT THEY HAVE SYMPTOMS.
WHAT WE CAN DO AS AMERICANS IF
WE WANT OUR CHILDREN BACK IN
SCHOOLS IS WE CAN HELP THIS
COUNTRY BY EVERYBODY DOING WHAT
THE PRESIDENT HAS ASKED, WEAR A
MASK, SOCIALLY DISTANCE, AVOID
GATHERINGS WHERE YOU CANNOT
SOCIALLY DISTANT AND WEAR MASKS
IN BARS AND HOUSE PARTIES AND
THIS WILL BRING THE CASE NUMBERS
VERY RAPIDLY IF WE ALTOGETHER AS
AMERICANS DID THOSE FEW THINGS.
PETE: WE WOULD LOVE TO HAVE TEN
STUDIES BUT SCHOOL IS COMING.
SO IS THE GUIDANCE GOING TO BE
FOLLOW PROTOCOLS AND MEASURES
BUT GET KIDS BACK IN SCHOOL?
DOCTOR: CDC HAS PUT OUT
GUIDELINES SO CHILDREN CAN GO
BACK TO SCHOOL.
I THINK EVERY SCHOOL DISTRICTS
AROUND THE COUNTRY AND CERTAINLY
WE HAVE MULTIPLE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS WHERE THE TEST
POSITIVITY IS UNDER 2% AND WE
HAVE A WHOLE ANOTHER SET OF
SCHOOL DISTRICTS AN COUNTIES
WHERE IT’S LESS THAN 5% AND CASE
COUNTS ARE EXTRAORDINARILY LOW.
WHAT WE WANT IS THE WHOLE
COUNTRY TO BE ABLE TO GO BACK TO
SCHOOL AND ALL OF THOSE CASE
COUNTS DOWN TO WHAT WE CALL THE
GREEN STATES AND WE KNOW THAT IS
POSSIBLE BECAUSE STATES HAVE
BEEN ABLE TO DO THAT AND
MAINTAIN THAT AND THAT’S THE
EVIDENCE-BASE THAT WE SHOULD BE
TALKING ABOUT.
WE HAVE EVIDENCE NOW OF WHAT
WORKS AND HOW TO MAINTAIN VERY
LOW CASE COUNTS.
THE REST OF AMERICA NEEDS TO
FOLLOW THOSE GUIDELINES AND
BRING THE REST OF US INTO THAT
GREEN CATEGORY.
AINSLEY: DR. BIRX, LET’S TALK
ABOUT HYDROXYCHLOROQUINE BECAUSE
THE PRESIDENT WAS SAYING THAT IT
HAS WORKED FOR SOME PEOPLE.
THERE WAS THE LOCAL
CONGRESSWOMAN THAT SAID IT SAVED
HER LIFE AND THEN YOU RECENTLY
HAD VIDEOS OF DOCTORS, I BELIEVE
IN TEXAS, SOCIAL MEDIA SITES
TOOK DOWN SITES BECAUSE SHE WAS
SAYING THIS COULD BE A CURE AND
HAS HELPED EVERY SINGLE PATIENT
AND NO ONE HAS DIED BECAUSE I
PUT THEM ON HYDROXYCHLOROQUINE
AND Z PACK, WHY ARE THEY BANNING
IT IF IT WORKS IN CERTAIN CASES?
DOCTOR: BECAUSE SCIENCE AND
MEDICINES HAVE ALWAYS BEEN FULL
OF ACCOUNTS LIKE THIS AND THAT’S
WHY YOU DO RANDOMIZED CLINICAL
TRIALS TO ACTUALLY BE ABLE TO
COMPARE PATIENT TO PATIENT.
EVERYTHING THAT YOU JUST
REPORTED ON HAD NO CONTROLS IN
THOSE INDIVIDUAL PRACTICES.
WE KNOW IN THE RANDOMIZED
CONTROL OF THE TRIALS TO DATE
AND THERE’S BEEN SEVERAL OF THEM
THERE’S NO EVIDENCE THAT IT
IMPROVES THE PATIENTS’ OUTCOMES,
MODERATE DISEASE OR SERIOUSLY
ILL IN THE HOSPITAL.
MEDICINE ALWAYS HAS THESE
REPORTS AND THAT’S WHY WE DO
THESE RANDOMIZED CONTROL TRIALS.
THERE ALSO MAY BE A SPECIFIC
SUBGROUP THAT DOES BENEFIT BUT
WE CAN’T SEE THOSE IN THE
RANDOMIZED CONTROL TRIALS.
AINSLEY: ISN’T THAT UP TO YOUR
DOCTOR?
WHAT IF YOUR DOCTOR SAYS
HYDROXYCHLOROQUINE OR MY DOCTOR
REMDESIVIR?
DOCTOR: LET’S SEPARATE ISSUES.
WE DID HAVE RANDOMIZE CONTROL ON
REMDESIVIR.
THE AMERICAN CAN HAVE ADVANTAGE
OF RECEIVING REMDESIVIR AND CAN
BENEFIT THE MOST.
THAT IS MOVING FORWARD.
MEDICAL BOARDS DECIDE FOR THEIR
STATE BASED ON CLINICAL
PRACTICES AND SO I’M ASSUMING
THAT OHIO HAD A VERY SPECIFIC
REASON IN ORDER TO TAKE THIS
APPROACH.
EVERY STATE HAS TO BE ABLE TO
LOOK AT THIS INDEPENDENTLY
BECAUSE THAT’S HOW WE ARE WITH
STATE DRIVEN WITH THOSE KIND OF
DECISION-MAKING.
PETE: ALL RIGHT, DR. DEBORAH
BIRX, THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR